Hello and welcome to fire of learning the 18th and 19th century,
a period in which warfare seems to stand apart from other periods in terms of
how wars were fought,
a stereotypical scene of this era,
our soldiers are arranged in groups,
in lines,
dressed and colorful uniforms,
wielding muskets,
marching towards each other calmly and taking almost choreographed shots at each
other at close range from the chaotic and explosive nature of war today.
That seems ridiculous and in fact suicidal.
Why will they fight like that?
A common response is that it was about honor that war was orchestrated by
gentlemen at this time.
Even sometimes that it looked nice and professional.
Well on the surface.
War was at this time considered a gentleman's dual on a larger scale by some and
honor and such.
Things were very important,
but that's not why soldiers fought in lines.
War at this time was as brutal and bloody as any other,
and logically,
of course,
if it were about honor,
all the commander would have to do is say,
forget,
honor,
switched to a more effective tactic and the battle would be his.
There was a reason for this style of warfare.
In fact,
many reasons that wars are fought like this.
Firstly,
muskets and the guns of today are very different.
A Brown bess musket that a redcoat would have carried during the revolutionary
war had an effective range of a maximum of a hundred yards and in altogether
range of 300 or so yards or about 900 feet.
It was hard to be accurate because the barrels were smooth and the bullets were
essentially round balls of led.
The ball could curve and miss the target very significantly,
so you definitely would not want your comrade standing in front of you as a
muzzle loader.
A trained soldier could get off about three rounds a minute or obviously one
shot about every 20 seconds accordingly,
with guns that are slow and have short range,
putting your men together in lines who fire in successive waves from the first
rank to the second ranked,
the third allow the soldiers to inflict much more damage than if they were
spread out.
Secondly,
remember that there were cavalry and artillery to contend with as well.
While artillery did target these clothes,
line formations fighting spread out,
made you very vulnerable to cavalry.
If you spread out your infantry cavalry could ride straight through them and
they could even be more susceptible to a melee charged from infantry.
Keeping them together allowed them to act as a wall and they could even form
things like square formations against incoming cavalry.
The square information was infamously successful at the battle of Waterloo
against Napoleon where the British and Prussians and other allied forces
repelled French cavalry several times.
And thirdly,
keep in mind that communications were much more simple during this era as well.
Shouts drums,
trumpets and flags were how armies communicated.
Not only could prolonged communication efforts slow the advance of an army,
but if a spread out army were divided,
communication would break down and a proper defense or assault could not be
coordinated.
Now you may be thinking,
well,
that makes sense,
but what about skirmishers or guerrilla warriors?
Why didn't those work?
Well,
they could have and they did.
Napoleon's voltage genre,
for example,
or the Pandora's fighting in the Austrian army.
Both skirmish or units often fought and looser formations to harass the enemy
and take off soldiers,
but fell back during the heavier fighting.
Furthermore,
guerrilla warfare happened quite often in this time.
In fact,
the term guerrilla warfare originated in his time.
It referred originally to the Spanish soldiers who fought against the points
forces with ambushes,
hit and run tactics,
raids,
and sabotage.
Another example of this would be the British Rogers Rangers,
or also known as the Queen's Rangers during the French and Indian war,
and also the American war of independence.
The French and their native allies also had guerrilla warfare soldiers in the
war,
and the American soldiers relied heavily on it during the revolution,
especially during the earlier parts of it.
And so now,
to the final point with this question,
how could soldiers have handled standing there with the potential of being shot
in an open field,
not even grown men,
but teenagers even as well.
It would have to be psychologically agonizing to stand there and face the enemy
in such a manner.
Well,
that's where the heavy discipline and the officers came in militias.
As a result,
we're often very unreliable.
Usually they were quick to flee.
In fact,
George Washington actually himself said that relying on militia was like resting
on a broken staff.
But even with more professional infantry,
one of the main jobs of the officers who commanded them was to control them from
fleeing.
And even with all this,
much of these battles eventually came down to melee combat after the two sides
valleyed a few times.
They fixed bayonets and charged into each other quite commonly.
As you might expect,
this style of warfare started to go out of style during the later 19th century.
When better,
more accurate rifles became more common.
Thus fighting in lines created massacres such as in the American civil war,
when machine guns,
radios and tanks enter the scene and the 20th century it was definitely done
for,
and thus,
I hope I've answered your question.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects be should check out
fire of learning and subscribed.
Thank you for watching.